so in high school yes your
superlative
if you will yeah was most likely to be
most likely to be a talk show host how
cool
i love that
that was one of the first things i
learned about you and i was like oh my
god we're gonna have so much in common
yeah exactly um would you mind taking
over
i wouldn't mind at all really
like take over the whole show
yeah um well all right okay so now we're
gonna do a super fun edition
hosted by sam at the final five
all right i'm not asking the questions
you're in the driver's seat you are the
host of this show
so
take it away yeah guys i've got a great
guest drew
[Applause]
drew
look i have never seen e.t can you
believe that i've never seen e.t neither
of my kids yeah and you know they don't
want to i don't know why well it's
classic it's classic i feel i've been
too embarrassed to like now it's been so
long i've been embarrassed to like sit
down just watch it on my own but i have
to but tell me in a sentence
how would you describe the movie to
someone who's never seen
it rad and surprisingly emotional mm-hmm
yeah yeah just actually that's good
so surprisingly emotional
true who do you think does the best
impression of you oh my gosh
um i'm lucky there are these incredible
women who
um
i
uh like kristen wiig does a great one
sarah paulson does a great one um
chloe fine fineman those are kind of the
reigning queen right now currently
uh
the 50 first dates yeah one of my one of
my favorites
rom-coms i love a rom-com so 51st dates
makes me cry every time it really does
the end of that movie makes me cry
what is uh one behind the scenes tidbit
from making that movie that you've never
shared
cameron diaz not to name drop she came
to
visit in hawaii and then she never left
so we got i had a hotel room and we got
the one next door and we had a common
room and it became uh party central for
the entire movie and we just had we had
well we put a ping pong table in our
room
and um it was
it was one of those moments that i'm not
sure if i knew
then
that it would be my one of my favorite
memories of life but i knew it was good
and and i tried to be present for all of
that
that's terrific and our room really was
party headquarters yeah of course of
course
i do i am obsessed with batman i don't
know if anybody knows that about me uh
but if you could be a superhero
who would it be
usually you get the uh what super power
would you have um
i'm gonna let you down this you can make
your own superhero with a superpower
that you'd like i would be superman who
could speed read oh yes
uh speed reading superman
i love that
i love that
all right drew uh we talked about 51st
dates you are the queen of rom-coms but
what is your favorite rom-com of all
time
um
probably dumb and dumber yes i love it
well you're a wonderful guest and you're
so good at that that you have suspended
me and transcended i'm like
and i think this is your show and i
should say thank you
and um i i feel like you know you should
read us out uh new episodes of the after
party debut every friday on apple tv
plus and we'll be right back
[Music]
you